use the rotation tool to determine the
angle of rotation about the point two
comma negative three the point two comma
negative three that will map
line segments h e and r o
onto the other line segments so we want
to rotate
h e this is segment h e and this is line
segment r o and we want to rotate it
around this point so that they map so
that their their images after the
rotation map to these two right over
here and let's think about it which one
should map to which so it looks like
it looks like h e
h e
should
should map to this right over here now
well actually before let me just play
around i can add a rotation
i could add a rotation here
and let's see i could rotate around if
this point over here is going to
well we already know we're going to
rotate around the point 2 comma negative
3 so let me write that we're going to
3 and let's see if we rotate by 90
degrees what happens
so that was
that was too
much so remember we wrote a positive
rotation actually that's too little
because a positive angle right over here
we're going counter we're going
counterclockwise by 90 degrees so point
r mapped to this point right over here
point o mapped to this point over here
but we want it to go even farther we
want it to map to maybe this point over
here so let me let me increase this i
don't know let me try 135.
all right it looks like we're almost
there maybe let's try 140.
press enter
that's still
that still didn't get us there let me
see 145.
oh we're getting close maybe 150
and that looks that looks pretty good it
looks like we have done it so if you
start with these the set of points that
represent line segments h e and r o
if you rotate them about the point two
comma negative three by a hundred fifty
degrees and what the convention is that
that's going to be counterclockwise we
see that we map their images are going
to be these two lines right over here
and we saw we saw that point o right
over here
maps to this point right over here point
r maps to this point point e is going to
map to that point i believe yep that's
right and then point h is going to map
to that point and obviously all of these
points in between for example this point
right over here that's on the line that
would map to halfway between these two
segments right over there so there we
have it we've done it